with almost 500 sessions that next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
several us on Google cloud what's new
then stay tuned because here's everyone
serverless
technology continues to innovate in the
cloud native space where that platform
takes away all the complexity that comes
with handling the lower-level
infrastructure so you get to focus on
what matters your code in this talk will
discuss all the new and exciting changes
since last year first we start with an
announcement that GCP has updated the
base image for service offerings to a
boon to 18.04 which gives access to a
broader set of system libraries and also
enables some new capabilities for the
product I write documentation for App
Engine who is celebrating its 10th
birthday this year originally shipped in
2008 was supported for only Python this
year appengine rolls out its
second-generation runtimes giving you
access to new js8 Python 37 and PHP 72
and while App Engine is celebrating his
longevity Google cloud functions is
celebrating its first year with a whole
set of announcements first cloud
functions is now available for all
developers making it production ready
and even provides an SLA along with that
is support for more regions scaling
controls so you can put an upper limit
on the number of instances of function
and languages including node 811 and
Python 37 both of which contain common
features like logs exceptions error
reporting and alerts all through
stackdriver
another great new GCF feature is
environment variables specific key value
pairs that are bound to a single
function but don't exist inside your
source code you set them at the point
I'm and they'll be injected as literal
environment variables at execution time
continuing with the updates GCS now has
cloud sequel direct connection support
as well as access and iam support
through VPC inter connect to a network
control access to function invocation
using I am on the invocation you can
assign a role of invoker to a particular
user
allowing you to define who can kickoff
which functions great for function of
function use cases
now something I'm really excited about
is the availability of a new tool cloud
scheduling which allows you to schedule
HTTP pub/sub tasks down to one minute
intervals invoke GCF over HTTP and
invoke App Engine on relative URL you
can start setting up timers for events
where you want to happen like cron jobs
for more information on all these
updates including a few live demos of
the technology and a top-secret product
release check out the full video linked
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the Google cloud
platform YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content
[Music]